en el vídeo pasado usamos la regla del
cociente para poder encontrar las
derivadas la tangente de x xi de la
cuota agente de x lo que quiero hacer en
este vídeo es continuar y encontrar las
derivadas de la secante de x y de la co
secante de x así que empecemos con la
secante de x voy a buscar la derivada
con respecto a x
secante de x de la secante de x y bueno
esto es exactamente lo mismo que
encontrar la derivada con respecto a x
de y recordemos la definición de secante
la secante es exactamente lo mismo que
uno entre el coseno de x esto es
simplemente la definición de secante
ahora para obtener esta derivada de aquí
se puede hacer de varias formas cuando
aprendas la regla de la cadena que de
hecho podría ser la cosa más natural de
usar para evaluar esta derivada de aquí
pero también saben por la regla del
cociente así que vamos a aplicar la
regla del cociente y no hay coincidencia
de que lleguemos a la misma respuesta
realmente la regla del cociente puede
ser derivada basándonos en la regla de
la cadena y la regla del producto pero
no voy a continuar entrando en eso así
que solo vamos a aplicar la regla del
cociente justo aquí entonces esta
derivada va a ser igual
y primero me voy a tomar la derivada del
de arriba la derivada de 1 con respecto
a x bueno eso va a ser cero estás de
acuerdo me va a quedar 0 que multiplica
a la función que tenemos abajo entonces
va a ser cero por coseno de x ok y a
esto hay que quitarle a esto hay que
quitarle la función que tenemos arriba
que es simplemente uno y a este uno lo
voy a multiplicar por la derivada de la
función que tenemos abajo y la derivada
del consell es el menos seno así que
podemos poner simplemente aquí el seno
de x ok y ponerle aquí un signo positivo
cambiar el signo así que todo esto lo
vamos a dividir entre el coseno cuadrado
de x
seno cuadrado de x
ahora bien 0 por coseno de x esto
simplemente se cancela esto es 0 y me va
a quedar 1 por el seno de x así que esto
es simplemente el seno de x el seno de x
dividido a su vez entre el coche no
cuadrado de x y hay múltiples formas en
las que podrás escribir esto mismo si lo
deseas lo podemos escribir así también
lo podemos escribir como el seno de x
esto dividido a su vez entre el coseno
de x que multiplican am
bueno uno entre el seno de x y es que si
lo vemos así ahora podemos reescribirlo
de la siguiente manera el seno de x
entre el coseno de x bueno eso es lo
mismo que la tangente de x y por otra
parte tengo uno entre coste de x que eso
es lo mismo que la secante de
así que podemos escribirlo de esta
manera
o podemos también ponerlo de esta otra
manera así que ahora vamos a hacer la
derivada de la co secante déjame
escribirlo aquí me voy a fijar en la
derivada con respecto a x de bueno la co
secante de x y recuerda la consecuente
de x es exactamente lo mismo que tomarme
1 entre el seno de x así que esto me
quedaría como la derivada con respecto a
x
bueno de uno de uno entre el seno de x
entre el
seno de x ahora esto puede ser que te
parezca un poco confuso porque puede
parecer que la consecuente de x el
recíproco de el coste no de x pero no lo
es es lo opuesto a lo que esperarías el
recíproco del coseno no es la co secante
es la secante de x y el recíproco del
seno no es la secante de x es la co
secante de x ya sabes tu esperarías que
si empieza con una s también es
recíproco compensada con una s y si
empieza con una sem
entonces el recíproco empezará con una c
pero en este caso no es así simplemente
es la forma en la que se definió pero
bueno en cualquier caso vamos a evaluar
esta derivada una vez más haremos esto
por la regla del cociente pero también
podríamos hacerlo usando la regla de la
cadena entonces esto va a ser igual a la
derivada de la expresión que tenemos
arriba lo cual es
que multiplica a la expresión que
tenemos abajo a la función que tenemos
abajo
de equis y a esto hay que quitarle la
función que tenemos arriba que es 11 que
multiplica a la derivada de la función
que tenemos abajo ahora la derivada de
estreno de x es cosa de x entonces por
josé no de equis y recuerdan todo esto
lo vamos a dividir entre la función que
tenemos abajo elevada al cuadrado y
ahora viene 0 x seno de x esto se
eliminan y me quedan simplemente menos
coseno de x esto entre el seno cuadrado
de
ahora bien esta es una forma en la que
podremos escribir esto porque también lo
podemos escribir de la siguiente manera
y usando la misma lógica que decimos acá
arriba esto es lo mismo que el menos
coseno de x que lo divide en el seno de
x ya esto lo multiplicamos por uno entre
el seno de
y de nuevo esto va a ser lo mismo va a
ser lo mismo que tenemos ahora el seno
de x entre el seno de x
esa es la cota en gente entonces me
quedaría - la otan gente de x que
multiplica a 1 el 30 de x que ya sabemos
que es la co secante de x o secante de x
así que cualquiera de estas dos formas
son válidas puedes elegir esta forma de
aquí
esta forma de aquí y ya está ahí lo
tienes